ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome to
the Huberman Lab podcast,
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor
of neurobiology
and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today is an Ask Me
Anything episode, or AMA.
This is part of our
premium subscriber channel.
Our premium subscriber
channel was started in order
to provide support for
the standard Huberman Lab
podcast, which comes
out every Monday
and is available at
zero cost to everybody
on all standard feeds--
YouTube, Apple,
Spotify, and elsewhere.
We also started the
premium channel as a way
to generate support for exciting
research being done at Stanford
and elsewhere, research
on human beings that
leads to important
discoveries that
assist mental health, physical
health, and performance.
I'm also pleased to inform
you that for every dollar
the Huberman Lab Premium channel
generates for research studies,
the Tiny Foundation has
agreed to match that amount.
So now we are able to double
the total amount of funding
given to studies of mental
health, physical health,
and human performance.
If you'd like to subscribe
to the Huberman Lab podcast
premium channel, please go
to hubermanlab.com/premium.
It is $10 a month to subscribe
or you can pay $100 all at once
to get an entire 12-month
subscription for a year.
We also have a lifetime
subscription model
that is a one-time payment.
And again, you can
find that option
at hubermanlab.com/premium.
For those of you that
are already subscribers
to the premium channel, please
go to hubermanlab.com/premium
and download the premium
subscription feed.
And for those of you that
are not Huberman Lab podcast
premium subscribers,
you can still
hear the first 20 minutes
of today's episode
and determine whether or not
becoming a premium subscriber
is for you.
So without further
ado, let's get
to answering your questions.
The first question
is about nature,
in particular about the
scientifically-supported
benefits of getting
outdoors into nature.
The person asks about
the role of sunlight,
the role of calming
sounds, the role
of observing wildlife, of
observing green colors,
and, quote, "other stuff."
And in fact, I'm glad that
they asked about "other stuff"
because I get the question about
the scientifically-supported
benefits of nature a lot.
I often also get the
question about grounding.
For those of you that aren't
familiar with what grounding
is, grounding is a practice of
putting your feet on the Earth
directly with bare
feet, oftentimes
into soil or on a lawn.
And it's a question that I
seem to get more and more.
In fact, every week for quite a
long while now, on social media
or elsewhere, somebody asks me
about the scientific support
for this practice of grounding.
So obviously there's
a lot of interest
in what the scientific research
says about getting into nature
and putting one's
feet on the ground,
a.k.a. grounding, and so on.
OK, so if I'm going to
answer this question,
I first have to be
very direct with you.
There is excellent,
meaning dozens, if not
hundreds, of quality
peer-reviewed studies which
support the value of getting
sunlight in one's eyes,
in particular early in the day
to set your circadian rhythm.
This is something that I've
talked about extensively
on the Huberman Lab podcast and
as a guest on other podcasts.
It's one of the first and,
frankly, most important
items on the toolkit for sleep,
which is a zero-cost toolkit
that you can access by
going to hubermanlab.com,
going to the menu,
going to Newsletter.
You can see it as a PDF there.
You don't have to sign
up for the newsletter.
You can just access
that toolkit for sleep.
And you'll notice that very
close to the top of that list,
if not top of that list, is
to get sunlight in your eyes
early in the day.
You don't have to see the
sun cross the horizon.
If you can, that's great.
But if you wake up after
the sun has already
risen, go outside,
face the sun, blink
as necessary to
protect your eyes,
but get some sunlight
into your eyes
every single day or as
often as you possibly can,
especially on overcast days.
That's an absolutely
unequivocally
science-supported tool that will
increase daytime mood, focus,
and alertness and will
improve your nighttime sleep.
Viewing morning sunlight also
has profoundly positive effects
on metabolism.
Now, those effects
on metabolism could
be the direct effect of viewing
sunlight or, more likely,
they are the
indirect consequence
of getting better
sleep at night.
So getting sunlight in
your eyes early in the day
and ideally in the
evening or late afternoon
before the sun sets is a
very well supported protocol
that we know is beneficial
for numerous aspects
of mental health, physical
health, and performance.
And of course, sunlight and
getting sunlight in one's eyes
does require that
you get outside.
You simply will not
derive the same benefits
from viewing sunlight
if you try and do it
through a window or
windshield or if you
look at a picture of
a sun on a screen.
Forget it.
You are not going to set
your circadian rhythm.
You are not going to derive
all the positive effects
of sunlight by trying
to get it from screens
or from looking at pictures of
suns or something of that sort.
Now, if you are somebody
that, for whatever reason--
seasonality, where you live on
the planet, work schedule, et
cetera--
who cannot get sunlight in
your eyes early in the day
on a consistent basis, well,
then you might consider
purchasing a so-called SAD lamp,
which is for seasonal affective
disorder, which is very
bright light that you can look
at in the morning for usually
about 5 to 10 minutes.
People will put it
on their counter
while they make their morning
coffee, eat their breakfast.
And that has also been shown
to improve mood, focus,
and alertness and set
one's circadian rhythm.
But it is not nearly as
effective as getting sunlight
in your eyes.
Now, why am I talking
about this practice
that I've already
talked about extensively
on numerous podcasts before?
Well, because the
question is about nature,
and sunlight is a key feature
of our natural environment.
But the person is also
asking about other features
of nature-- seeing green
colors, or blue colors,
or running streams
for that matter.
Well, here, too, we can ask,
what does the scientific data
really say about
things like going
near a waterfall, or a running
stream, or being near an ocean?
And actually, this
is quite interesting.
There is actually a
peer-reviewed literature
on negative ionization,
as it's called,
which is a pattern
of ionization that's
present close to bodies of water
and particular types of bodies
of water, such as waterfalls,
running streams, et cetera.
There's actually a laboratory
at Columbia University School
of Medicine that has
published fairly extensively
on the health benefits
of negative ionization
as it relates to
setting circadian
rhythm and some other aspects
of mental and physical health.
I intend to host the
head of that laboratory
on the Huberman Lab podcast
in the not too distant future.
For now, we can
safely say this--
there does seem to be
some positive health
benefits to placing oneself
near bodies of water,
in particular moving
bodies of water.
And of course, as is always
the case when there's
a discovery about how the
natural world can impact
health, there have been
some technologies developed
to create negative
patterns of ionization
within a home environment.
But as with viewing
sunlight exposure
and comparing it
to, say, SAD lamps,
the negative ionization machines
that one can purchase and put
in their home environment have
been shown in a few studies
to produce some positive
health benefits.
But those positive
effects in no way
reach the level of
positive effects
that have been demonstrated
in studies where people
are actually
spending a dedicated
period of time outdoors as
near a moving body of water.
So in thinking about nature,
natural environments,
there's strong evidence for
getting sunlight in one's eyes.
There is some evidence for being
near moving bodies of water,
perhaps--
again, I really want
to highlight perhaps--
because of negative ionization
created by those moving
bodies of water.
There is far less evidence
for sunlight simulators
or negative ionization
machines used indoors.
And then the asker of this
question also, quite correctly,
asked about things
like calming sounds,
watching wildlife,
green colors, et cetera.
And herein lies a really
important point for everyone
to digest.
While, of course,
answering a question
about the natural
world or about health
requires that we first pose a
hypothesis-- for those of you
that aren't familiar
what a hypothesis is,
a hypothesis is a
stated prediction.
So it's not a question.
A question would
be something like,
is getting out into nature
good for our health?
A scientific hypothesis is where
one actually takes a stance.
For instance, you
could take the stance
and make the hypothesis
that getting out
into nature for 30 minutes
per day, three days per week,
improves mood and
nighttime sleep.
So that's a hypothesis
that then one would go on
to design an experiment
to test and then evaluate
the data from that
experiment and compare it
to the hypothesis, either
validating or negating
that hypothesis.
That's essentially
how science is done.
There's a lot more to it,
but that's essentially
the scientific method.
And while, of course,
the scientific method
is a fabulously powerful
tool, for some questions,
it is a less potent tool.
And the question of is
getting out into nature
helpful for enhancing our
mental and physical health is
the sort of question
that while ideally you
could design a really well
controlled study to address,
it's actually quite difficult
to design such a study.
And here's why.
In order to perform a study
that's very well controlled,
meaning where you can isolate
individual variables--
like sunlight, like the sorts
of color contrast that one sees
in a natural scene outdoors
in a forest or near a river--
in order to address
whether or not
the calming sounds or the
presence of squirrels running
through your environment
are the relevant factors,
it becomes incredibly
difficult to try and isolate
individual variables, meaning
as soon as you bring people
into the laboratory, yes, you
have more control over which
variables, as they're
called, you present them,
by bringing them into a
room that essentially has
no art on the walls and
then having them look
at a picture of a sun
or looking at sunlight
or listening to soothing
sounds or looking
at a picture of a
forest, of course,
you're controlling the
individual variables.
However, there is
a sort of gestalt,
meaning a collective
picture of being
in nature that
brings together lots
of different elements--
the element of surprise,
for instance.
The other day I was
out for a Sunday hike,
and that morning I
saw a squirrel running
across my path, and
it was interesting
because the squirrel had
a pinecone in its mouth.
It had been chewed
down to the cob.
And the squirrel was probably
only about 7 or 8 inches long,
and the pine cone was probably
about 9 or 10 inches long--
the cob of the
pine cone, that is.
And the interesting thing
is that the squirrel
was carrying it long ways
from the tip of the cob.
And so I delighted in the
fact that this little squirrel
was working so hard to carry
this object through the woods.
And this object was literally
longer than its own body
length, and it looked so
dedicated in its running
across the path in
order to do whatever it
would with that pine cone cob.
So something like that
obviously stuck in my memory.
It delighted me.
And at the very same
time, there were a number
of other things happening
besides the presence
of that novel
wildlife experience.
There was the sound of a stream.
There's the sunlight.
There's the color
contrast everywhere.
I'm breathing
fresh air because I
was far away from any cars
or any civilization, in fact.
And so here's what we know.
There are dozens,
if not hundreds,
of studies that show
that if people get out
of doors into nature--
this could be parks.
This could be near a stream.
This could be an
ocean, any number
of different natural
environments.
And if they do that for
anywhere from 10 to 30 minutes,
three to seven days
per week, indeed there
are demonstrated
significant reductions
in things like blood
pressure, resting heart
rate, improvements in
sleep, improvements in mood.
And so I think we can very
reliably say that, yes,
or perhaps even absolutely yes,
getting outside into nature
can enhance various aspects of
mental health, physical health,
and thereby performance in
different aspects of life.
However, when talking
about the benefits
of getting into nature, we are
talking about hundreds, if not
thousands, of variables, some
of which we are aware of,
such as the presence of wildlife
or sunlight or color contrast.
And then, of course,
there are going
to be dozens, if not
hundreds, maybe even
thousands of other variables
that we're not even aware of.
Perhaps it's
negative ionization.
Most people aren't measuring
the ionization of the air
when they go out into nature.
But perhaps it's
also the presence
of certain smells from the
soils that are being broken down
and then they're changing the
oxygenation state of the air
around you, the
plants, et cetera.
Again, so many
variables, that, frankly,
to try and isolate any
one of those variables
in the laboratory seems
not just artificial,
but I think that it
actually would just
lead to a diminished sense of
just how valuable nature is.
So while, of course,
the Huberman Lab podcast
is a podcast where
we always center
on science and
science-related tools,
meaning protocols
that are grounded
in quality peer-reviewed
studies that have been subjected
to control conditions where
some people are getting,
say, the drug treatment
or taking the supplement
or doing a particular behavioral
practice and other people
are not or doing some variant of
those and dose response curves,
all of that stuff, when it
comes to the question of
whether or not it's valuable
to get out into nature,
I think it's a very
straightforward yes.
Absolutely yes.
Get out into nature as often
as you can and safely can,
of course.
I realize some of this
is weather permitting.
People live in different areas.
Some people are in cities.
Some people are in deserts.
Some people are near the ocean.
But getting out into nature has
been shown over and over again
to have numerous
positive health effects.
And yet, unless we're talking
about sunlight exposure
and isolating the variable
of setting one's circadian
rhythm by viewing sunlight
early in the day, all
of the other features of
getting out into nature,
things like forest bathing--
this is a term coined from some,
frankly, pretty nice studies
that were done in Japan in
which people placed themselves
into forest-like environments
for a certain period of time.
There were control groups
where people were not
placed into those
environments, and the people
that did this so-called
forest bathing experienced
enhanced mental and
physical health.
That brought on a practice of
people who could not get out
of doors into forests
bringing plants
into their home environment,
which I think all of us
would agree look nice.
They often will add
pleasant odors to the air,
and perhaps they do actually
shift our mental and physical
health in significant ways.
I suppose it depends on
how much you like plants,
how much you pay attention
to them, and, of course,
how many plants there are.
But-- and I think this
is a really important
"but" to emphasize--
while most all questions
about tools and protocols
for enhancing health
immediately lead me to say, ah,
this study or that
study or, yes,
there's evidence or, no, there
isn't evidence, when it comes
to questions about nature
and grounding in particular,
I take the stance that this
is a unique instance where
we know there are just so
many benefits of getting out
into nature that
trying to isolate
any one of those
variables in a quality,
rigorous way within
the laboratory
almost seems too artificial
to really justify
the conclusions that arrive.
Now, I'm sure there are some of
you out there who are aware--
and if you're not,
I'll tell you-- there
are studies that have
explored this practice
of so-called grounding.
They've had people come
into the laboratory
and place their feet on soil
that is contained within a box
or there are other studies
where they actually
have people go out of
doors and place their feet
onto the grass or the ground.
And there are a
bunch of theories
as to how grounding
could improve
one's mental and physical health
that aren't just about getting
outside.
So the theories go
that this has to do
with the exchange of
electrons with the Earth
and the Earth's
surface in particular.
There's been the
argument made that shoes,
in particular shoes
that have rubber soles,
may block some of
this electron exchange
with the surface of the Earth.
There have been theories
about the tactile--
that is, the touch sensation--
with the Earth being important.
Not a lot of science
published in, let's just say,
blue ribbon journals,
which is not
to diminish some of the journals
that these have been published
in, but just to say that, again,
there are so many variables
associated with a practice such
as grounding that I'll simply
say, yes, please do get
out of doors into nature.
I try every Sunday to do my zone
2 cardio by rucking or jogging
or hiking, often
with other people
if I'm trying to be social
with family or others.
But the point is
getting out of doors
has myriad positive
effects on mental health
and physical health.
And of course, when you're
moving out of doors,
you're also getting that
zone 2 cardio or other forms
of physical benefit by
elevating your heart rate
or perhaps you could even do
your resistance training out
of doors on other days.
Now, I also try to get out of
doors other days of the week.
But oftentimes, I'm,
by way of weather
or by way of other commitments,
forced to be indoors,
on planes, here at
the podcast studio
where certainly I'm indoors.
But I try and get out of
doors at least a few minutes
each day for a morning stroll,
looking at sunlight, et cetera.
So the long and short
of this is, yes, there's
some evidence for grounding.
Is it super strong evidence?
No, it's not.
We don't really know what it
is about placing one's feet
onto the Earth that is producing
the positive effects that
were observed in those studies.
And those studies made
some reasonable attempt
to isolate the variables and
figure out whether or not
it was ion exchange with
the Earth or the tactile,
meaning the touch
sensation, of having
one's feet on the ground.
Frankly, I don't think
there's enough quality science
to really draw any firm
conclusions about that.
However, if you like the idea of
grounding, by all means, do it.
In fact, if it
feels good to you,
I recommend getting your
morning sunlight out
of doors with your bare
feet on the ground.
Or if you're like me,
you put on your shoes,
and you take a walk most days.
Although, I've tried this
practice of grounding,
and it feels pretty
good, meaning
it feels nice to have
my feet on the Earth,
provided I'm on clean
soil or clean lawn.
Definitely don't do
this at the dog park.
Hookworm is a real
thing, by the way, folks.
So pay attention to
the sorts of surfaces
that you're putting
your feet onto.
But the question about
whether or not nature
is valuable for our mental and
physical health is an easy one.
It's an absolute yes.
But isolating the particular
variables about nature
that are most beneficial, well,
that's a much tougher question,
and it's one that, frankly,
the scientific method is not
and, to be honest,
I don't think ever
will be in a position
to isolate and really
nail down specifically, because
as soon as you get specific
about that question,
you start to diminish
the value of the study itself.
So the long and short of
this is get out into nature
as often as you safely can.
If you can exercise out
of doors, even better.
If you want to make
it social, great.
If you don't want to
make it social, fine.
It's your life.
It's up to you.
But there certainly is value
in getting out into nature.
It's also just beautiful
from a visual perspective,
from an auditory perspective.
And I myself try and take at
least a few trips each year.
None of these are
particularly expensive trips
where I try and get
out hiking, camping.
The weekly walks in nature
are an absolute must for me.
If I miss one because of
weather conditions or travel,
I make it a point to
try and get into nature
more during the following
week or whenever I can.
And frankly, I don't have
a scientific explanation
for why nature is
oh-so beneficial,
except for the sunlight piece
and perhaps this grounding
piece and the negative
ionization piece.
And frankly, I
don't worry so much
about the lack of
variable-isolating, quality,
peer-reviewed studies that
support the benefits of getting
out into nature.
I simply like getting
out into nature
and into different
natural environments
as much as I possibly can,
because, for whatever reason,
imagine those reasons have
something to do with serotonin,
dopamine, hormones,
oxytocin, probably
a bunch of different
things that are
rooted in how our
nervous system evolved
in natural environments.
Well, it just feels really good.
Thank you for joining
for the beginning
of this Ask Me Anything episode.
To hear the full episode and to
hear future episodes of these
Ask Me Anything sessions, plus
to receive transcripts of them
and transcripts of the Huberman
Lab podcast standard channel
and premium tools not
released anywhere else,
please go to
hubermanlab.com/premium.
Just to remind you why we
launched the Huberman Lab
podcast premium channel,
it's really twofold.
First of all, it's
to raise support
for the standard Huberman
Lab podcast channel, which,
of course, will still be
continued to be released
every Monday in full length.
We are not going to
change the format
or anything about the
standard Huberman Lab podcast.
And to fund research--
in particular, research
done on human beings,
so not animal models,
but on human beings,
which I think we all agree
is a species that we
are most interested in.
And we are going to
specifically one research that
is aimed toward developing
further protocols
for mental health, physical
health, and performance.
And those protocols
will be distributed
through all channels, not
just the premium channel,
but through all channels,
Huberman Lab podcast
and other media channels.
So the idea here is to give
you information to your burning
questions in depth and
allow you the opportunity
to support the kind
of research that
provides those kinds of
answers in the first place.
Now, an especially exciting
feature of the premium channel
is that the Tiny
Foundation has generously
offered to do dollar-for-dollar
match on all funds raised
for research through
the premium channel.
So this is a terrific
way that they're
going to amplify whatever funds
come in through the premium
channel to further support
research for science
and science-related tools for
mental health, physical health,
and performance.
If you'd like to sign up for the
Huberman Lab Premium channel,
again, there's a cost
of $10 per month,
or you can pay $100 up
front for the entire year.
That will give you
access to all the AMAs.
You can ask questions and get
answers to your questions.
And you'll, of course, get
answers to all the questions
that other people ask as well.
There will also be some premium
content, such as transcripts
of the AMAs and various
transcripts and protocols
of Huberman Lab podcast
episodes not found elsewhere.
And again, you'll be
supporting research
for mental health, physical
health, and performance.
You can sign up for the
premium channel by going
to hubermanlab.com/premium.
Again, that's
hubermanlab.com/premium.
And as always, thank you for
your interest in science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]